What do you look for your living?
Did you say, "What do I look
for in a woman?"
-No!
That is not the question, but, yeah, true!
No! Wait, no, what
was the question?
-What do you
do for a living?
I'm a sleepyhead.
Are you a morning person?
Every morning. Absolutely.
-Oh, my God, I'm not.
-You're not a horny person?
-I would like to be!
Is that what you said?
-"Morning! Morning!"
-Oh! I was like, "What?"
-I grew up in the beautiful
tropical islands
of Puerto Rico.
Pure-blooded Puerto Rican.
My accent? Oh, my God.
It's a hate and love relationship.
There's some that
do understand me,
but there are some like,
"Lydia, what the hell you said?"
-I am single 'cause
I haven't been
fortunate enough to
find someone
who is emotionally matured.
Oh, mature enough!
-In the past, I've been
called "too much."
That has definitely, like, impacted me.
-Oh, my God, girl!
-But I don't think I'm too much.
I think that I am the right amount of me.
-There we go!
-I am smart. I am brilliant.
Howdy.
-I wanna be really loved for
this amazing person that I am.
-Hey, what's going on?
-Who is the lovely guy
that I'm talking to?
-This is Milton. Who is this?
My name is Lydia.
I am from Puerto Rico.
So what do you do?
I'm a geologist.
Oh, my God, I'm really big
into metamorphic rock.
-Metamorphic facies.
-You are? Why?
Are you a geologist?
I'm an engineer
in the middle of geology.
You're an engineer!
-I'm in between geology
-and engineering.
-Oh my God!
-I have a polarizing microscope
in my apartment.
Oh, my God, you're such a nerd.
I collect samples.
You're such a nerd, Milton.
So, Puerto Rico
has a little bit of everything.
At the north, is, like,
the quartz zones.
So, sedimentary, right?
Okay, I hate sedimentary
rock, but I work in
oil and gas, so
I have to like it.
-Sedimentary goes like…
It's excised easily.
It's not stable.
I feel like sedimentary is,
like, the weak spectrum.
I'm so sorry.
We're talking about, like,
diagenesis sedimentary, right?
-Right. Yes.
-That's my shit.
Oh my God, we're getting
really nerdy here.
I love it.
If you're into, like,
rocks and minerals,
then we can observe things
under my polarizing microscope.
-I'm down.
-Oh my God.
You're such a
nerd. I love it.
-Okay, I'm really not.
I don't usually go
for a nerd though!
-We have, like,
the same passion
and, like, the same
background.
That's pretty dope.